just don't go her own party tonight I
guess all right
donc over Paul don't look at him like
that JR all this [ __ ] with Brett is like
a brother hoodie know we we talk all the
time we play golf he talks to me about
basketball cause he loves again so much
and I'm he's like a little brother
probably okay oh man good I'm the man
just chillin I hear that just chilling
there it is
my name is Brett hammer furry I'm trying
to five years old
I broke the United States were right
there on golf
you're special about dicks I gotta go
battle I've been playing golf since off
three years old
and a large area sniff like okay like a
better than me
juniors friendship with Brad is just
exceptional we come here but junior
comes to all Brad's events plays with
the national Down syndrome event I
played golf for Brad handful of times
he's coming to my tournament I was about
six years in a row now Brad is a huge
inspiration especially for jr. when TR
sees him before the game start it's like
that extra boost of energy but sometimes
he a point to Brad the Brad does this
back to join that's a big Dahmer right
there
take you turn emissive are you know
raising money for the kids giving
scholarships Jeff Smith is just
phenomenal what he does was torment to
donate all this money to youth
organization for underprivileged kids
here you go
Japan nice so won't agree your lights
over damn course I am right is a great
golfer he's on a fair way every time
any player extreme confidence and that's
Justin ego he does exceptionally well in
practices three four days a week we
don't give him no disability here hell
no Brad will beat you if you let him he
letter
to varsity sports in high school with
with golf and basketball he proved to
the whole world that kids with a
disability can do just as much if not
more than the so-called normal person
can do birdie putt I got a warp nice
wine yeah I say the math take take par
I mean brush be an inspiration to
everybody you know how hard he works
what he wants to do he wants to be just
a normal kid and have the same goals and
dreams like everybody else I'm a fake
offer yeah I work out a lot
I got a few jobs you know what you talk
about disability at times I get
emotional about it but uh
I don't look at his bread as a
disability I'm just a golfer I like
anybody else
let's give ya good good nice man
of course yeah you know I bet I know who
I'm at yes sir ok ready go 1 2 turn over
you know four things first please buddy